ja bedeutet dass ein ticks heute es muss
ja noch eine zweite impfung erfolgen
aber mit dem einen keks den manche
menschen heute erhalten ist damit schon
mal viel getan wie schon einiges
erreicht wir sind manchmal sehr viel
drüber ist in dieser studie die diesen
impfstoff jahre ausführlich den usa und
andere länder geht es herausgekommen
dass nach der ersten ungefähr 50 prozent
mindestens 50 prozent schutz erreicht
wird aber auch natürlich die zweite
impfung um eben diesen hohen schutzlevel
die sowohl schutzrate von über 90
prozent zu erreichen aber schon erste
impfung hat einen erheblichen gefegt
viele menschen haben dennoch sorge vor
möglichen nebenwirkungen vielleicht
können sie auch hier aufklärungsarbeit
leisten was kann überhaupt im
schlimmsten fall passieren wie sicher
ist die impfung ja zunächst mal hat
mancher fahrer aus dieser studie
im prinzip sind die nebenwirkungen
ähnlich wie bei anderen impfungen
aufmerksam unter umständen schweren
haben man kann sich einen tag lang
unwohl fühlt und sind eher von leichten
schnupfen man als kantine erhalten das
ist so das was häufig aussieht ganz
selten sind auch allergische reaktionen
beobachtet worden wie gesagt ganz selten
und das ist auch durchaus nicht ganz
unglücklich bei impfungen das kommt auch
bei anderen lebensräumen vor dass sie
die schäden die man bisher die die
nebenwirkungen die man bislang
beobachtet hat langzeitbeobachtungen hat
man natürlich im augenblick noch nicht
dann muss man eben zu warten aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass da stimme und
wirkungen entstehen ist eigentlich
relativ gering
können sie uns ganz kurz sagen was
diesen neuen dem stoff also der von bei
und tech und der nächste der von der
us-firma moderner kommt das sogenannte
mrsa impfstoffe was unterscheidet die
von herkömmlichen bisher bekannten
sogenannten vector impfstoffen division
impfstoffe sind werkstoffe bücher
auszuleihen aktivierte partikeln
verwendet der unterschied ist hier auf
meinem im prinzip die den bauplan für
die eigentlichen richtigen proteine das
anti die antigene substanz und jetzt
hier so dass im körper kreist dieses
protein dieses video bezahlen antigen
gemacht wird und dann neben dem
immunsystem präsentiert wird so dass man
eben hier quasi einen relativ direkten
weg hat um die hand
gehen und dieses protein zu generieren
vorteilen ist auch noch dass man diese
impfstoffe relativ schnell modifizieren
kann und auch relativ in großen mengen
produzieren kann
das ist bei anderen impfstoff direktor
impfstoffen oder inaktiviert partikeln
das ist da deutlich schwieriger soll
markt einige vorteile durch diesen darin
ein impfstoff jetzt haben wir das team
aus thüringen gehört und wir haben
daraus bayern gehört da gab es eine frau
die hatte vor zwölf tagen eine
grippeschutzimpfung wer sollte sich denn
jetzt nicht impfen lassen
daneben 14 tage zwischen der letzten
impfung mit einem anderen impfstoff
liegen haben sollte dann ist auch noch
bislang tatsächlich so dass unklar ist
ob man eben menschen ihm sollte die
bereits corona durchgemacht haben das
wird auch im augenblick von der
ständigen impfkommission nicht empfohlen
sondern das sollte man erst mal die
erfahrung zu sammeln
menschen die noch keinen kontakt hatten
grundsätzlich ist es aber so dass
menschen die es ihm vor die die
infektion unbemerkt durchgemacht haben
offensichtlich aber auch kein größeres
risiko haben denn auch die menschen
waren ja in dieser studie nicht bereits
erwähnter wirkt dabei so dass man im
prinzip im augenblick eigentlich fast
alle impfen können kann die ausnahme
neben der kommentar ausgeschlossen sind
kinder sollten nicht geimpft wenn im
augenblick was da kandidaten gibt oder
einer schwangerschaft sollte man
vorsichtig sein aber auch nicht
was ist denn mit leuten die den
allergien wir haben jetzt diese wenigen
fälle unter anderem aus großbritannien
gehört was ist mit leuten die bekannte
medikamenten allergien oder andere wo
der andere allergien haben was müssen
die machen uns erklären dass sie
empfehlen können
dazwischen gibt's mal mit dem
entsprechenden arzt der dabei dienten
dabei ist kontakt aufnehmen
beziehungsweise es auch mitteilen
und dann wäre ja die menschen die da
geimpft werden in der regel auch
überwacht das heißt also im prinzip ist
die allergie zunächst mal kein
ausschlusskriterium aber es sollte halt
entsprechend ja auch genau aufpassen und
springt der aufklärung betreiben
wie gesagt allergie ist im augenblick
kein ausschlusskriterium aber keine
ausschlusskriterien und die audi die
fälle die berichteten sind wirklich sehr
selten
und wie gesagt es ist tatsächlich so
dass auch bei anderen fuß so was
auch immer wieder auftreten kann herr
professor blatter ist mir auch viel über
die risikogruppen gesprochen die er
heute mit der impfung staaten
mich würde aber auch interessieren ist
es sinnvoll kinder zu impfen wird auch
das irgendwann passieren so ein gewisses
problem wir wissen mittlerweile dass
kinder eigentlich nicht schwer kranken
und normalerweise ist man natürlich um
demjenigen der gegend städten schutz zu
vermitteln denn der markenschutz braucht
dann ist das natürlich eine ethische
frage
denn damit geld geredet man natürlich
zunächst mal schutz für die herren für
die allgemeinheit
ich glaube das wird noch sehr gehen auch
in die ethikkommissionen diskutieren ob
dann irgendwann auch kinder geimpft
werden im augenblick gibt es keine daten
für die kinder da gibt es auch keine
studien
das heißt man ist da relativ weit davon
stand im augenblick überhaupt das zu
diskutieren
wie gesagt weil die kinder auch im
prinzip zunächst einmal selbst kein
großes risiko haben wenn sie keine
entsprechenden grunderkrankung haben
wie lange hält diese impfung überhaupt
also wie lange bin ich denn dann gesetzt
das ist natürlich die wichtige frage die
sich viele jetzt stellen
das kann man wirklich noch nicht
beantworten das wird man nicht genau
natürlich überprüfen müssen es gibt
gewisse hinweise aus den laboratorien
man kann das geologisch untersuchen ob
eben entsprechend mager der erde der der
immunität entstehen die er unter
umständen bleiben aber natürlich wir
haben einen sehr kurzen beobachtungszeit
an das heißt wir wissen nicht wirklich
gut wie lange sich diese impfung hält
wie lang der schutz hält und dann wird
man natürlich auch und das ist jetzt der
letzte letzten tagen wochen auch
entsprechend diskutiert wurden werden
auch station in zürich zu rechnen haben
das heißt es kann durchaus sein dass man
dann noch mal ähnlich wie zb bei der
grippe impfen muss weil sie eben der
erreger verändert
aber auch da hier hier dass sich der
kraftstoff wird einen gewissen vorteil
raum an denen auch dann relativ schnell
auch anpassen kann